so dear colleagues good afternoon i want
to welcome you for our extraordinary
imca meeting i'm very happy that the
room is again a little bit fuller after
two years of pandemic and interactio and
connection problems i think it's great
that we have again a lot of people in
the room today
especially because we have such an
important such two important agenda
items both related to the landmark
legislations the to the two pieces of
legislation that are basically still
undergoing but almost finished
the digital service act and the digital
markets act so if there's no objection
the agenda is adopted i have as usual
some
short chairs announcements um there's
different
languages available for interpretation
unfortunately not danish looking at our
danish colleague who will speak soon
but anyhow your english is perfect um i
know that so um the meeting will also be
web streamed and um
let me
remind you again we have a new
newsletter and on our mco website it's
always very
valuable looking at it and to see what
kind of important files we as emco
committee are working on
um so with that we directly move to
agenda item
three
where we will have
i would say again a report back a but a
more detailed thorough um report back on
what happened exactly in the last trial
looks we know that all of those trial
looks happen in the night
we of course try to inform everyone on
twitter and
be as transparent as
as possible but of course we wanted to
also give a little bit more room um to
show in our committee um on what we
worked on so intensively in the last one
and a half years and what are actually
the results that the european parliament
achieved for the eu citizens but also of
course for the eu businesses
for the online world um so with that i
would like to give the floor um to our
first or two reporters of these files um
yeah to give them um a little bit the
stage and uh debrief us what has been
achieved in these two important
legislations we start with andrea schwab
from the epp our rapper tour on the
digital markets act please andreas
first of all let me just say
that i'm very happy to have the
opportunity to be the first to speak
here
but i would just
like to say
that
we are able to sit together today and
discuss two pieces of legislation and
if that's possible then
it's to the credit of all of us and so
i'd like to thank everybody for the
support and the faith you've placed in
me and i'd like to thank the staff for
their commitment to the task to have a
bit broader outlook about the results
and it's true that the digital markets
act and the digital services act which
has been done by my colleague crystal
charlemon they have a very strong
interplay and it's also about a
political assessment and we have to
acknowledge that also the french
presidency has helped a lot
by speeding up the process and by
looking
without any
too difficult procedures for compromises
and most important we have francis hogan
with us today and we have met her
already in the procedure and i think it
has been a very helpful contribution
because on whatever we have been
discussing here and i have experienced
that also in the aftermath of these
negotiations
there is always assault especially in
the area of the digital markets act of
blackmailing situation because companies
that suffer for market failure or for
dominance of specific companies they are
just scared to speak out
and therefore it has been helpful
extremely helpful
and that our parliament has made
hearings but also that some
people like miss hogan have been having
the courage to speak out on specific
tools that we as parliamentarians we are
not always aware of in detail and
therefore it's great that we take the
time today to exchange and i would like
to report to you quickly about the trial
outcomes about the most important ones
the digital markets act to a certain exp
expect expectation is unfortunately
backward looking because it takes stock
of all the competition policy procedures
that we have been seeing that have taken
too much time
and um what we wanted to do and and that
some colleagues have been pushing for
that a lot we wanted to make it more
future proof and more future oriented
and for that reason we have been
introducing some key provisions that
haven't been foreseen and that are not
part of that backward looking experience
that are to a certain extent just
changing the burden of proof to already
passed procedures that the european
commission has done in competition
policy against these big companies
the big tech
companies
so
i would like
to make very clear first of all the
procedural and enforcement elements are
extremely important for long-term
results first
i think this parliament has made clear
that gatekeepers have less options to
cheat although in algorithms normal
citizens have no inside view it's not
any more possible to have delaying
tactics in the designation approaches
procedures
or in the regulatory dialogue that will
create openness and even further in
article 5 and 6 and my colleagues have
been spending an awful lot of time in
looking into the details of it we have
also been trying to create as much as
openness as possible without destroying
the innovation effect of these companies
in the digital market
and in addition we have been making sure
that the commission gets stronger
sanctioning tools in case of systematic
non-compliance the parliament made it
easier to apply structural or behavioral
measures and we have introduced also a
temporary merger ban
in relation to the scope chairwoman
colleagues i think we have been
discussing a lot but procedurally
probably the most important is that with
the intermediary services we have an
open door for whatever the market will
show and that will make this law more
efficient that people have sought at the
beginning
now also because of the hearing that we
had with miss hogan
some months ago the parliament
significantly strengthened the
obligations also with regards to
companies like facebook
in the aftermath of the scandal on
cambridge analytica because the data
combination for which colleagues have
really been fighting hard we have
avoided that data data combination will
continue to be used in between core
platform services that you are a good
company and that you have a strong
service that's fine and that you can use
the data that you create and that you
get there it's fine as well but if as a
gatekeeper you want to switch these data
to other services that might be much
less performant that will not be
possible anymore um or it will only be
possible if the consumer and the user
and that's the people that we care most
about here give their consent
i think there are plenty of elements
that i could now dwell on i think some
of them we will
touch on in the exchange later i would
like to mention the interoperability
element that we have been introducing
also here some colleagues have been
fighting very hard
it's true that it's an unperfect
situation because the interoperability
obligation only is there for companies
that come up with a reasonable request
and want to connect with gatekeeper
services so we are not yet in a full
interoperable system but it's a first
step to make more
contestability of markets where there is
already a strong dominance and we have
done the same with some specific
solutions like choice screens default
settings and uninstallation give as to
users a greater choice and and all these
together will allow markets to grow and
then i would like to come
to the final point in that list
chairwoman and this is the fair
reasonable and non-discriminatory
approach
obviously this is a new concept in this
law because it has been applied in some
other areas so far but from our point of
view the front principles are there for
everyone for sure for app stores but
also for other players because fairness
and reasonable and non-discriminatory
conditions is a general principle in the
european union and therefore we expect
gatekeepers in the area of app stores
social media and search to respect also
this and all this together has been only
possible i mentioned it already chairman
because this strong support in this
committee and of other committees in the
house and therefore i would like to
conclude that why the dma draft was
backward looking the parliament has
taken a view of the future and ensured
that the text will be now future proof
for sure there is a lot of work for the
commission to be done and we will also
remain grateful during the whole process
if people like francis hogan will
testimony and will give us insights on
what can be done better because
obviously there is still a lot to be
improved and that's what this parliament
wants to work on and that's for i think
all the work that we have done was
useful and we are looking now to the
future in the digital markets area
and there are other areas to be covered
soon thank you so much
yeah uh thank you andreya schwab for
this report back i think you did a
tremendous job in uh finding a
parliament position i think
strengthening the european commission
proposal as you said for example with
this forward-looking element but also of
course in defending um the parliament's
negotiation positions in
the trial looks and i guess with this
file and also with the second file we
just
will talk about um i think we as
european union show also especially in
the light of
these worldwide crises that we have that
we are
able to deliver and i think that is
quite important so with that we go
to the second
legislation the digital service act
where we also equally will hear our
rapper turquoise
for a report back and the summary of
what happened and what was the outcome
thank you so much and also from my side
i i would like to thank also our
committee to give us a chance to go more
into depth about the the impact not the
impact on the result of our negotiations
and i think it has been
really a very important two pieces of
legislation we have been making here and
it would not have been possible without
the very good help from our staff and
from
the shadows etc so i think that we can
be proud of the process as well and also
the speed i have to say that
when i in the beginning of the process
said that well i think that we should
try to
finalize the dsa during the french
presidency
manny said to me do you think that's
possible
but luckily it was and before i go into
the content i also have to say that i
would like to thank the state secretary
cedric oh as well he's with us online
and when i saw him i i wrote to him that
i kind of missed our conversations even
though they were sometimes very
difficult
but we really spent some time together
to try to find solutions but i think
that every one of us can be proud of the
result and later on
we will also talk about more of the
global consequences when we have this
the next 0.4 but there is in my opinion
no doubt about
the impact of the dsa will be global as
well
but what did we do
um first and foremost i think that it is
maybe good to remember people that we
received the commission's proposal in in
december 2020
and after that we
tabled here in the parliament more than
3
000 amendments and many many committees
were involved both
with the classical opinion but also
associated committees so we really
really made a good job even though it
was sometimes also complicated um i have
always defended
the quality over speed but i think that
what we have achieved here is
showed us that it was possible both to
make a good quality legislation at the
same time do it very very fast
um
i also think that we with this
result sends a clear signal to the tech
industry what is illegal offline should
also be illegal online
and if you're not taking your
responsibility to ensure to ensure a
safer online environment then you will
be sanctioned and i think this is a very
clear and very important message
so what
did we do well
we
built upon the e-commerce directive
which we adopted back in 2000 year 2000
and we are maintaining
some of the core principle from the
e-commerce directive including the no
general monitoring obligation and the
country of origin principle
so
nothing in the dsa will
will oblige platforms to do
active fact-finding or make a general
monitoring of the content of their
interfaces but
and also the free movement of services
across the eu will be
guaranteed
because it's still the applicable law of
the member state in which the service is
established that will apply so this is
important to send that signal but we
also did more and we said that we will
keep the principle of limited liability
for uh for the platforms however we also
made things that they have to comply
with and if they don't comply then they
will of course become liable that's the
way we did it so in general i think that
we
made a good
list of
rules that will make a better
that will ensure better choices for
users of platforms no matter whether
you're a citizen or you're a consumer or
a business user you will get more
you will get more choices we also try to
protect consumers by banning dark
patterns we have
made a ban on online targeted
advertising based on profiling of miners
as well as a ban on targeted advertising
based on profiling
using a sensitive data i think this is
important this is the first step
to stop the platforms
from misusing our data so i think this
is a very important achievement and on
that i would also like to thank andreas
and the team on the dma because we made
these two things together in the two
legislative proposals
so
in addition to this we also agreed to
have greater transparency for online
advertisement in general for instance
by permanent and harmonized marking of
advertisement including from influencers
so they will be a part of this
legislation as well and we have also
ensured and i the next i mean everything
is important but this is very dear to me
we also ensured stronger protection of
minors for instance by obliging the
online platforms
accessibility to miners to put in place
measures to ensure a high level of
privacy safety and security for miners i
think this is important
and also we have made rules about the
greater transparency requirements for
recommender systems as well as uh rules
on uh also more transparency and
transparency for for the terms and
conditions
and thirdly we are also introducing new
and stronger rules for online
marketplaces
with the dsa agreement
we have introduced specific rules for
online marketplaces we have strengthened
the traceability of traders as well as
putting in an obligation for random
checks
to ensure that consumers can safely buy
services and products when that are in
that are complying with eu law
so enforcement and sanctions uh are not
always efficient uh
and therefore we also thought that it
could be useful to give the consumers
even or the users of platforms even more
uh chances to to make sure that that
they had the right to they had some
rights they could
uh yeah
enforce so we
also introduced a right for compensation
for any user who has suffered a damage
due to non-respect of the due diligence
obligations
this is a way also as an addition to
protecting citizens from illegal content
and products as well as from negative
impacts on algorithms to ensure i hope
better algorithm accountability
i will keep on because the time is
running and i will try to not go into
many details but i also think that it's
very important to mention that we ensure
that european smes
they will not face disproportionate
obligations this has also been a very
important topic for for the parliament
we will try to make sure that we can
help them innovate and grow
and therefore we have introduced a grace
period for medium-sized enterprises so
if they have been small and become
medium-sized then they will have a
period of 12 months before they have to
comply with the
the new rules i think this is a very
good help for companies in order to make
sure that they will er
have time to understand the new rules
and finally or not finally but we also
managed to ensure stronger obligations
for very large online platforms
and this is really something new
we
made
new rules to make sure that we have
algorithm accountability we're trying to
open up the black box of algorithms and
we do it by demanding the platforms the
very last ones to make a yearly on a
yearly basis
an assessment on
on how their algorithms affect the users
and society
we want them to look into the effects of
the algorithms for instance on hate
speech or cyber violence
but also on a revenge pawn and cyber
bullying and things like that so we are
really trying to ask them to open up and
in case they don't uh and in case they
find problems they have to risk mitigate
this is also a very important
thing that hopefully can help us
making a more trustworthy environment
online
and they should also assess negative
impacts effects on misleading or
deceptive content such as disinformation
and if they
find any risk they have to adopt
measures to mitigate the risk identified
so with this i think that we really can
see
a more safe online i hope so and in
addition to this we had a very lengthy
debate on it as well but we also
introduced a crisis mechanism
allowing the commission to act upon the
recommendation on the board of
national digital service coordinators
to require very large online platforms
and also very large online search
engines
to apply specific measures if there is a
specif specific threat to
public health
or public security in case of an
extraordinary situation like a war or
like a pandemic or maybe a natural
catastrophe so
we also asked the platforms to make
independent audits and we also have made
sure that we give access to data and
algorithms to the commission and to the
digital service coordinators of
establishment
and vetted researchers embedded
non-for-profit organizations and
associations should also be able to get
access to data and algorithms if of
course they fulfill certain obligations
but i think this is also part of opening
up the black box of algorithms and i
think that that will really help us er
making sure that that we know that this
legislation will be
enforced
and coming to enforcement on the very
large online platforms we decided
that the commission should have the
power uh for the supervision of very
large online platforms and search
engines like in the dma and i think this
makes sense and in order to make sure
that they have resources to
make this
supervision
and enforcing the rules in a good manner
we also decided to
make sure that there will be a
supervisory fee that the platforms have
to pay
so that we're sure that that there are
enough money and if a
platform is not complying with the rules
uh finally they might be
getting sanctioned with a fine of
maximum six percent of their annual
turnover worldwide i could speak for
many more minutes i will not do that but
the list as you can hear is long and
what we have tried to achieve is both
looking at the user side all the
different users and the society side and
also the company side that we want to
make sure that we have a level playing
field that we protect consumers that we
protect our democracy and i do think
that we can all of us be extremely proud
of this result it will have an impact
not just in europe but globally in the
world thank you very much
yeah thank you also um to you um crystal
chaldemus very much our rapper tour who
had the difficult task not only
integrating the different views of
political groups but i think also that
shows our democracy is very strong
because we had different ideas we had
heated debates but we came to a good
result but also integrating all the
other committees that made such an
important contribution i think um to our
imco work
and as you said the list of achievements
is quite long but i think we will
probably also discuss in our second
agenda item today a little bit longer
also with the other members present here
now i would like to give the floor um to
the french
now i have to say i guess former french
minister of state for digital transition
and electronic communications um cedric
oh because we wanted to give both co
legislators today here and the
opportunity to speak um i think it is
really important and that we had
basically a negotiation partner that of
course defended also his line from the
council but also was open to arguments
which also achieved at the end a quick
and swift result in both files and so he
earlier like oh um i give you the floor
now and you're connected online i guess
yes
yes thank you chair good morning
thank you for giving me a chance to
speak today
on the major successes for europe
of the digital architect and the digital
services actually quite right
i ceased to be administered two days ago
i'll i can come back to that but i have
an opportunity now to
pass the ball on to you to take this
further now regarding the two texts
under discussion
before
addressing the substance repeating what
crystalline and andreas and said i'd
like to welcome
the form
of the text and how things proceeded
in general terms
i think it's very important for europe
that in less than two years altogether
we were able
as far as digital relations concerned to
table
context of
historical
importance
to paint them and to mend them and i
trust in all logic
to adopt them in the next few weeks
i
welcome
the uh
the animated the spirit that informs
your work of with
and andreas and um
and
crystal scandal the most
in their work respectively as reporters
on
dsndma i'd like to thank both reporters
of course
as well as um mr steger the vice
president of the commission commissioner
but also all the members of the e3
committee and the reporters in the other
committees as well as your cell phone
since you played an important role in
ensuring
that we were able to keep the pace up
and uh
i was very upbeat about the atmosphere
that performed on work this means that
we have these two new ticks
table now the digital service out in
digital market as far as i'm concerned
having spent five years um
serving france in in europe in this area
i i think are the most important
attempts
i think they uh are absolutely crucial
now i won't return to the very specific
points mentioned by andreas and crystal
in their presentations
regarding the digital market act of the
digital services act
i think
the content is very full now
and it's going to be hard for us
to gauge the real impact of legislation
until a number of years have gone by
given how rich they are and the the
wealth of subjects they address we will
need a number of years
in order to assess
what will really have changed
taken as a whole
i'll start with the digital market act
i think this is important in completely
resetting the way the digital economies
work
the question of anti-trust measures and
fighting the constitution of the market
are global concerns
within the new economy you can see this
reflected in the legislation adopted in
south korea or the current debate in the
united states
as well as other countries
i think there's a global consensus
regarding the need
to
adapt the rules governing the way we
regulate the markets
along the lines mentioned by andreas
determines on the real
world where
essential
structures are regulated but we need to
match that now to the digital market
if you draw an analogy with
bridges and
airports i'm sure no one would imagine
that
just their private owners could regulate
them properly
you you can't have people who run the
motorway just deciding off their own
bats what um
the fee to charge
and that is just inconceivable and the
same applies very much
to the way we regulate the digital
market
given the inherent concentration on the
digital market
given the the platforms the the search
engines and so on it's vital to ensure
that there is proper public scrutiny of
the course of events
and i think
the digital market act will definitely
do that i feel convinced of that it
marks not just economic progress but
democratic progress if you look at the
history of anti-trust legislation
follow it back to the end of the 19th
beginning of the 20th century
you'll see look at these and the others
who envisaged
american anti-trust legislation at the
time
looked at standard oil and the railways
as requiring
democratic scrutiny it wasn't just an
economic imperative
i think this will create a an earthquake
and it's absolutely vital as for the
digital services act
as you know that addresses the issue
of liability or at least
negotiation of content
everyone has mentioned to the point that
reaching an agreement on this topic
of
the dsa in six months was something that
you could take even less for granted
than the digital market act given
cultural specificities of the various
countries of europe and i really do
welcome the fact that we managed to
achieve this with the two co-legislators
together with the commission
all hauling in the same direction
as um
as you're saying earlier on the
uh madam chair i'm going to miss the
discussions with the the care reporters
and everyone
in the future
now there are two major principles
written into the dsa which i think
absolutely vital
if you look at
the the terrible
killings in in buffalo the other day
i think it's absolutely vital we can
make progress on these issues
so the first principle is transparency
the opaque workings of the platforms at
the moment given the role they play in
our democracies
and
the way they provide guidance or to
channel public debate
means
that we have to bring that opacity to an
end
we need to know
how content is governed why does certain
content get onto that form and not
others
if you're looking at facebook or twitter
we we see this capacity as as an
admiration for democracy
so
the regulators
but also
researchers there has to be access to
the information that's vital for
democracy in the years to come and the
second final principle is responsibility
or
now without encroaching on the
e-commerce storage i think it speaks for
itself
that
if you build great power you also have
to shoulder great responsibility
the major platforms
are not doing what they should to reduce
risks
and must be held responsible
for their
failure
to apply resources to this issue that's
crucial
the implementation of the dsa in the
months and years to come
will significantly change people's
day-to-day experience when it comes to
disinformation and
cyber
bullying suffered by our fellow citizens
the new report new approach on
regulating the market mentioned by
crystal sultan was it just now
is essential that there's a feeling of
urgency
when you have dangerous products being
sold on certain platforms today you can
see that crying need
so at the end of the day we have two
texts here
strong into
linkage regarding
the infrastructure and the content
you couldn't have one without the other
we have a body of european law here
which will be bolstered in the future
by further registration
crucial piece of legislation that
set out a european course of of action
in the digital sphere
all this will have to be implemented
however i know that's something that's
close to the heart of the european
parliament hole and the two rapporteurs
it's going to be a struggle
the timing for implementation
is ambitious
but i think these two texts and once
again i'd like to thank everyone
involved
europe
is turning a new page in the regulation
of the internet merci beaucoup indeed we
had a very tough negotiations with the
council going on also in late night
hours but at the end i think it was a
very cooperative approach i want to
thank you very much again and wish you
all the best for the future in your new
job or whatever might come um
i want to also use the occasion and
thank the commission we will not have um
vice president best tire or commissioner
here today but of course they were
present at all the trial locks
and we're always together with their
staff
acting as an honest broker supporting
the two largest co-legislators so with
that i also
want to thank the commission um
so now their colleagues we move to the
next the second agenda item for today
where we will in fact now discuss
the impact and especially also the
global impact of these two landmark
legislations and for that we have
a guest here i welcome also on the
podium
francis hogan
thank you for being here again with us
um i think your speech in when was it
november here in this committee in this
house gave a lot of inspiration
to the lawmakers and also pushed i think
our ideas on also tackling the business
models of the platforms and not only
looking at the surface but also looking
at the algorithms and of course also
looking at targeted advertisements so
very happy that you are here um you know
that we will um do a mission with this
committee to silicon valley to also
exactly discuss discuss the questions
what is the impact then on other states
on for example the united states or
other states in the world
of the dsa and the dma and of course we
are also very interested in hearing your
opinion on the outcome that we just
listened to from our two rappers and
from the state minister
um so
i welcome you very much again would like
to give you um the floor but of course
also welcome the commission
representatives because at the end we
will also hear um from the commission
and your colleagues you can already
prepare now we will also have the time
to
discuss from all the shadows repertoires
all the political groups um the outcome
again of course and also the question of
the global impact of this legislation so
welcome very much uh i give you the
floor
i'm starting to lose my voice a little
bit so i definitely need water one
second
wonderful
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today
i'd like to start with a heartfelt
congratulations on reaching a political
agreement on the digital services act
a landmark agreement that will make
social media less toxic for users
the digital services act is the most
significant piece of social media
legislation in history
it goes to the heart of what i've tried
to do as a whistleblower who worked
inside of facebook
make social media far better without
impinging on freedom of speech
in europe we will now be able to see a
modern alternative to the current
whack-a-mole approach to content
moderation that results in endless
discussions on which particular piece of
content should stay up or must go down
instead the dsa focus on the oversight
of the design
and implementation of systems rather
than determining what is good or bad
speech
one of the core reasons that i came
forward was that facebook's current
strategy of
focusing only on content moderation of
only allowing the public to participate
in the question of how to regulate
social media the focus on content
moderation was a strategy that didn't
work in a linguistically diverse world
facebook is very different than other
industries with similar amounts of power
if we were talking about an oil company
or a car company we would have the
ability to inspect the products of those
companies we could buy a car and we
could crash it we could put sensors on
the car and see does it actually pollute
the way it claims to
if children were being harmed near an
oil derrick we wanted to take the word
of the oil company that oh no no no it's
the clouds that did it not our smoke or
it's not us or the pollutants we could
go check ourselves
facebook is is different because we only
ever see our screens
all the choices that impact us all the
trade-offs happen somewhere mysteriously
far away
and up until now facebook has taken
advantage of that secrecy
to operate in a very different way that
they've they've only given us a tiny
little slice of the conversation they
framed it for us and said this is what
we're allowed to talk about
the reason why the dsa is so important
focus on systems is so important is that
when we build safer products
we get safer products for the entire
world no matter what language we speak
i was in denmark maybe two days ago oh
yesterday i was there yesterday morning
sorry the world is
it's very fast
there's only maybe seven million danish
speakers
do people not deserve to be safe because
sex excuse me there's six million even
fewer there's six million danish
speakers um there's more than norwegians
and i was in norway just a couple months
before that but norwegians and danes
deserve to be safe too just because they
speak smaller languages and the spoken
focus on systems really shows that
europeans are are used to living in a
linguistically diverse democracy and you
understand the value of those cultures
and the diversity and we need to show
tech companies that they need to design
in ways where everyone is safe no matter
what language they speak
this is the right way forward and it can
be a model for other countries around
the world
the dsa will be the first instrument
that creates a holistic set of
obligations for tech companies which
will force them to properly assess and
mitigate the harms of their products
that they can cause
tech moves incredibly fast and will only
continue to move faster focusing on
responsibilities and obligations is a
way to be more future proof by focusing
on risk assessments and on process
instead of
pointing out the specific features that
we want changed
this means for the first time digital
service providers will have incentives
to put people over profit when they're
facing a choice between profit
maximizing strategies or the public
interest
employees inside the companies will feel
supported to do the right thing when
assessing potential risks of product
design choices
we have the backs of the people who have
great who have strong consciences inside
of facebook but giving them the space to
do the right thing
this sounds revolutionary but it is
standard practice in other areas of our
economies global companies had chosen
profit maximizing strategies at the
expense of the public interest before
we've seen it with pollution in the
chemical industry environmental damage
in the national natural resource
extraction
economy and predatory mortgages and
financial services
what distinguishes the bad practices of
these other industries from big tech is
simple there are laws holding them
accountable
that's what government is intended to do
in democratic capitalism
use the law to steer the market back
into alignment with the public interest
when concentrated monopolistic power
privileges the few over the money and
distorts how the free market operates
this kind of correction is vital
this is not about protectionism this is
about protecting the interests of
citizens all over the world
these rules are like the systems in the
united states that compel pharmaceutical
companies to keep drugs safe and to
allow the food and drug administration
to independently verify the results
most people aren't aware of them but
we're all glad that they're there
as an algorithmic specialist and data
scientist i'm most excited by the dsa's
new requirements for access to data for
researchers auditors and regulators this
will allow independent research and the
impact of social media products on
public health and welfare
for example
facebook and instagram and others will
have to open up the black box of which
pages posts and videos get the most
likes and shares shining light on the
outcomes of the algorithms
this will allow thousands more people
not just those who work at these
companies to address the complex
problems of how information markets
change social outcomes
no longer will be depend on taking the
company's word for it when they say they
are trying to fix a safety problem
democratic and investor accountability
and oversight of big companies boils
down to whether we can accurately
diagnose the problems their products are
causing
devise solutions and verify that the
industry is actually following through
with them
the era of just trust us is over
hence i am pleased to see that some of
the most innovative parts of the dsa are
actively being discussed in the united
states with both parties increasingly
cooperating to understand the joint
challenges and potential solutions
to improve transparency of content
moderation algorithmic amplification and
data access for researchers monday's
statement from the eu and the us trade
and technology council between the eu
and the u.s is encouraging as it
promises more alignment on these topics
in particular by advancing data access
for researchers in the united states
europe has laid out a path that we can
adapt in our uniquely american way and
learn from
finally i want to end with a strong call
on all of you and your respective
governments to put your money where your
mouth is
the law cannot remain a dead letter
strong enforcement is absolutely
critical to achieve meaningful and
positive changes
we are living in difficult economic
times with rising inflation the war on
ukraine and the still ongoing coven 19
crisis all having significant budgetary
impacts
but we need significant resources to
make the dsa a success story
this will require investments to train
auditors and regulators it requires
resources to build new data analysis
infrastructures it requires resources to
attract people with the right profiles
the eu has a unique chance to get this
right
and i wish you all the courage to make
the right decisions in order to make it
a success
thank you so much for putting so much
hard work into this i know it was hard
but it's going to change it's going to
change history it was really important
and i'm so grateful for everything you
guys have done thank you
[Applause]
yeah thank you again for all the work
you have done um i think um we as policy
makers also rely on people like you who
have the courage to speak up when they
see uh problems um and i think yeah this
was also
basically
your contribution and think that we
ended up at the legislation how it is
now so thank you for that we have now
actually around um of of colleagues who
want to contribute and probably also
potentially ask questions to you and at
the end you will have the chance to to
reply again we start with
our
dshadow for the epp avocalari
okay thank you very much chair and hello
francis welcome to the european
parliament i want to thank you for
coming here and
giving us very important insights i
especially want to thank you for being
here
in the autumn when we had the hearing
when we were
legislating and i'm
i'm one of the negotiators for the
digital services act and represented the
biggest group in european parliament and
i must say i mean i think most of us
think that the internet in generally has
improved our life so much better in
general
um and it will continue to revolutionize
the world but i think we also can agree
that enable to have a free and open
internet we need to have a safe and
trustable internet
so i i think finally
the digital services act will
is sending a clear signal that we want
to have a safer internet with clear
rules for everybody with consumer
protection and a more business friendly
environment
and i think this has been welcome from
many stakeholders and we've done our
best to really to make a good proper
legislation that i think hopefully can
also be as a role model for other
countries to follow
so
i see that in the united states the
legislators there are looking into the
digital services act and what we have
done here and i i really hope that that
could be the the guiding principles also
for the u.s to uh to make to have an
open uh space digitally with with strong
safety and and
and and and user-friendly way and to
make sure that we really tackle what is
illegal online more properly that we
have done uh right now so from my from
my perspective i want to thank you for
your contribution it's been very
important for us
and and
i really hope that this will benefit
all citizens in europe all businesses in
europe and hopefully to create
a standard globally on how to make the
internet more free and and safe
thank you
yeah thank you abba now our ideas
abrasive castle charlie moser for the
smd
thank you very much and and dear francis
thank you so much for coming here today
but also in november uh i think that uh
without your visit
to eu
or even your whistleblowing your
testimonies i don't think that we would
have had such a strong and good dsa as
we delivered i think that you have been
really
important in that role you have been
inspiring us but also you became the
point of reference when we discussed
well
you said you said and and suddenly we
had a common conversation about the
problems as andrea said it can be
difficult for us to know in details how
companies work and and how things are
when we make legislation but it became
more visible and more uh understandable
for for us and i do truly believe that
you have played a very important part of
this so thank you so much
next week we are going to san francisco
and we're going to discuss and talk with
stakeholders on this landmark
legislation
and i hope certainly that we will
inspire
united states i think that we are
setting the
global standards
on how to regulate uh the online
environment and social media
and especially as you said on the
algorithms i think we're doing something
really new and that will have a huge
impact
but my question to you is what could
your advice be to us going to the united
states what could we say what do you
think is important uh what could be the
way to make them also
understand that this is not a burden it
is something that we're doing to create
a trustworthy environment that makes
people wanting to go online everyone and
not just a few so what would what could
we do i would be happy to hear something
but thank you very much for your role in
this as well
thank you crystal um so we do a
collection yeah yeah
um so now i give the floor for renew um
to the character our scheduler for you
thank you very much anna and
thank you frances it's really a pleasure
to see you again in in the parliament
and i'm happy that after such a short
time we see you again
that we can
say we deliver it
uh first time when we met we discussed
the the the risks that you saw that many
citizens actually wanted us to to
uh to fix
and now i'm happy to see that we have
managed to to do so
the biggest question for me is
the implementation
because we can have wonderful laws we
can have wonderful wording but the most
important is the implementation
the fact how
our national government how the
commission
will get it right to get to providers to
really start doing something and avoid
the last resort which we put into the
legislation
how to push them that in advance they
start taking measures and that would be
for instance my goal of the visit in the
us to really push especially the big
ones to start thinking what they must do
i think the sooner they accept better
i also think what is crystal clear that
we make sure that not that no tech
giants are above the law
there are no digital islands
and that
every everybody in this big
system from apple google meta
has to really re react take more
responsibility uh and act i would also
add that this is just the first step uh
it has been already set by by cedric i
think what we are actually doing now in
europe is i would say the opening of the
floodgates
we have already
number of other legislation on the table
ai cyber security
data act among others we we keep hearing
from the telecoms that they want to
overturn the net neutrality principle
for instance so there are so many that
is happening currently in europe for me
as a liberal person i would say that we
can see at the end of
less fair internet and that we will see
more and more regulation
and i'm a bit concerned that we have to
get it right to find the right balance
between what is actually needed in this
fast growing environment on one hand and
on the other hand how not to kill the
innovation
so thank you very much
again keep an eye on our forthcoming
legislation and hope to see you again
here thank you
thank you dieter and now for the greens
alexandra giza who was also the green
shadow raptor for the dsa
thank you cheering thank you francis
good to see you again
um
i i would like to to outline what your
contribution was in europe we had the
initial proposal on the table and we had
some ambitious ideas on how to improve
it
but without you we wouldn't have had the
proof for our criticism because um the
narrative in europe was
that facebook and eventually google were
being manipulated by external actors but
you brought the proof that it's really
the mechanisms the business model the
algorithms themselves that are the
problem and that really turned the
narrative
and without you we wouldn't have
achieved a political majority for our
more ambitious goals so
what did we achieve what is this
landmark legislation i would like to
quote shashana zubath who is a harvard
emerite professor of economics and she's
the author of surveillance capitalism
which is a little bit the theoretic
background of what we are discussing
here
and she said about the dsa dma that it
is the first comprehensive declaration
of a digital future
founded on the legitimate authority of
democratic rights and the rule of law
and the signal that the principles of a
self-governing demos might survive
the digital century and i would like to
say it's a signal that a self-governing
demos can thrive in a digital century
so what we really did here in europe is
we tuned the tide
we stopped that sense of inevitability
that a handful of corporations
would decide the roots on a global level
influencing public opinion when
transparent algorithms
for example disseminating disinformation
shrinking the space for a free press
through a draw holistic control of the
advertising market and threatening a
free economy based on a combination of
monopolistic power and data control
but what we did also achieve is we broke
up the black box
because
these companies the very large ombre
platforms will be object to public
scrutiny when they post risks to
fundamental rights and human dignity and
that means the dsa is also dynamic
legislation because we will be able to
conduct research accessing the the
platform's data and the more data the
more insights we gather the better we
will be able to regulate so the dsa dma
for me it's just the start because it
allows us
to tell the stories of how they're
influencing our world and then we as
society we can decide how they how we
want to live
so my question to you is you said
enforcement is crucial and we know that
how can we support
those researchers
who will do this absolutely precious
jobs to really analyze the details of
how the platforms work what are the
harmful mechanisms what are good
mechanisms
the ones who are going to tell the
stories how can we
support them
in order to develop the regulation
further if it is needed and to have
platforms that really enhance democracy
how can they team up
how can the organizations who ask the
right question on the protection of
miners for example on the fight against
this information how can they team up
with organizations that have large data
analytics capabilities
what can our role be what do they need
and what kind of advice would you give
to the european commission and to the
national digital services coordinators
who were responsible for the oversight
and hand who will need to build up an
enormous expertise and have the chance
to be a global center for expertise for
platform regulation thank you
thank you so much so now i have on my
list um the id coordinator virginia
um
thank you madam chair
thank you miss hogan
for sharing your expertise with us
as one of the shadows on the dma i think
this legislation is a step in the right
direction it could end the omnipotence
of the big tech companies but it could
have been better
the parliament's standards were brought
down
and these non-compliance measures will
come into force later i think
the
thresholds
for gatekeepers
need to be introduced as quick as
possible
what we've always wanted to do is
protect european users and we want to
have a level playing field for our
european companies
in the digital arena thanks to the
excellent negotiations led by andreas
schwab
the damage to the initial european
stance european parliament stance was
lessened
so many
uh of
your
proposals were taken on board ms hogan
whistleblowers are protected and the
uh
the the clauses on that are quite clear
and protecting whistleblowers will be
very important and it has been supported
by the political groups and it survived
negotiations with the council as you
know miss hogan the big tech companies
will do everything they can to hide
everything that they're doing wrong it's
thanks to courageous people like you
that the truth has come to light we
should support whistleblowers not just
by applauding them but by ensuring that
they have legal protection
thank you very much we move on to our
ecr header rapper for the dsa adam bilan
thank you very much chair
the chair miss hoygan ladies and
gentlemen
in the context of rapidly evolving
digital technologies and business models
but also new societal
challenges we faced the need to reshape
the rights and obligations
of digital markets and service providers
as well as internet users
in the eu i welcome the conclusion of
the digital markets act and thank adra
andras the french presidency and
commissioners for their hard work in
closing this file
the dma can be a step forward to making
our companies more competitive globally
but this is predicated on smes in
particular being able to maximize the
opportunities
created by the disruption introduced by
the act
new possibilities such as greater access
to data or more players in the
advertising market
will bring benefits
but mostly to those smes with capacity
and experience
in digitizing their offers
growing this capacity will be key
i have already written to the commission
on this regard and regret that the
response showed complacency
unfortunately no additional support was
envisaged by the commission despite the
huge changes that dma will bring
i believe this approach will need to
change and i am sure that the commission
present here today will share my view
that specific measures are necessary for
european smes to be successful in global
markets
under the digital services act and i
would like to congratulate a crystal on
her achievement we have achieved our
goal the online environment is now set
to become much more transparent and
safer for users
in parallel my group sold first and
foremost to guarantee freedom of
expression online and rule out
incentives for platforms to remove user
content to hastily
we also managed to introduce better
tools that will allow users to defend
themselves against arbitrary decisions
of internet giants
users will finally be able to challenge
moderators decisions
all of these achievements not only
defend fundamental rights online for
europeans but also are on the right
track to set the global benchmark for
regulated online platforms in the future
in this context i hope that the
other jurisdictions in the world will
learn from our experience and will take
cautious steps with regards to services
key to the online world such as cloud
services search engines so that open
internet and freedom of expression are
always granted
thank you
thank you so much before i take
the left i can
let you know that we have probably two
slots for catch the eye so if you want
to speak and catch the eye let me know
now first come first serve but now first
the floor to answer free pillow here
from the left
yes yes i gave you already the floor but
sorry further left for the left yes
thank you anna
thank you miss hogan for being here
again
i want to pay tribute to your courage
and the extremely useful work that
you've been engaged in you as
whistleblowers really help us when we
draw up legislation on the major
platforms
the dma and the dsa could be more
ambitious in our eyes that's what the
left in this parliament thinks
we think it could help the european
market and the world market
european legislation will force the
platforms
to comply with new obligations
hopefully
our standards
will
apply to the rest of the world
we need to look at content moderation
though you said last year that facebook
content moderation
was not
of a good standard for
languages other than english
under the dsa we now have transparency
mechanisms and under the audits and the
risk analysis we will have a better idea
of how content in the eu is moderated
one
how does the u.s legislation look at
content meditation
do you think it could
force facebook to look at content
moderation seriously at a worldwide
level i have a second question many ngos
including consumer organizations are in
favor of the dsa but they say it's not
ambitious enough my group wants to ban
targeted advertising completely outright
to stop profiling of
citizens and consumers
we do have a ban of targeted
advertising for children and
advertising that's based on sensitive
data such as health data we think the
bands could have been fuller could have
been better but we've got somewhere
can
big tech be moderated without their
business models their basic business
models really being affected
for you what are the shortcomings in the
legislation what can be done to better
regulate big tech companies thank you so
now the two catch the eyes are kim vance
barntek and dietrich cloon
and then we have the commission and then
we would love to hear your answers so
kim
thank you very much and thank you very
much ms hogan for being here again and
good to see you here again
and thank you again for teaching us
about the dangers of divisive
interaction-based recommender algorithms
and their impact on our society and
democracy
i think the new digital services act
which will regulate the internet creates
more transparency and will open up the
black box
but of course the next step is always
taking action
so
what would you say all are the
alternatives for the divisive
interaction based recommender systems
and could you perhaps tell us a little
bit more about
the chronological plus id um that you
touched upon last time you were here
and do you think it is enough to leave
it to businesses to change their
interaction-based systems or do you
think we should be a bit more
prescriptive in this thank you
yeah thank you so much also for being
concise and precise so now editor
clinton thank you thank you chair and
i'll be
put concise as well i hope and thank you
to francis for being here again with us
last november
when you came and i think it was
eye-opening for all of us really your
insight into what goes on and how
particularly young people and minors can
be targeted and profiled and use the
example of driven to polarize rather
staying in the middle if you show an
interest in i don't know eating habits
or diet that you can end up on polls so
have we done enough now um i mean i'd
like to hear your insights into that and
what what will this mean now for
young people that we really wanted to
protect with this legislation i think
it's it's it's a very important um
particularly what we've included in the
legislation now it is important and um
do you think that this will do it and
what will be the reaction in facebook
from your knowledge from your internal
knowledge and your experience with that
company thank you
thank you so much and because both of
you were so concise we have actually a
third i catch the eye and i think it's
also important because a stephanie
yokotan was also the repertoire and the
econ committee so peace
thank you very much
i'm glad to see you here glad to see you
here miss hogan
i'm the reporter for the associated
committee
so the econ committee
which looks at competition matters
you were quite right when you said that
this
text has to come to life has to be
translated into reality i think it's a
good text but i question its efficiency
and effectiveness dieter asked about the
governance and the means you talked
you spoke about
various issues i want to talk about
sanctions i think the sanctions could be
higher and the remedies
when it comes to the legal remedies
we've heard that they're not
enough
what about
just destructuring or decommissioning i
know there's a lot of talk about that on
the other side of the pond is it
technically feasible i know there are
many uh discussions about that if you
look at facebook would it be
possible to
to deconstruct it to better regulate
that giant if i give you
the floor um we have as i announced a
commission representative we have mr
gerard craft he's director
digital of digital transformation
in synecd
so
in the room or online yes in the room uh
welcome and of course we are also
looking forward to your comment uh
also questions if you have questions to
ms hogan
thank you very much madam chair
honourable members also very pleased to
see madame haugen here and thank her for
her contributions to the debate um
of course we are very pleased with the
outcome of the dsa in the dma thanks to
the parliament it's a more ambitious
text it's a better text
and it will therefore have or should
have more
impact we hear very clearly also the
message from the parliament
about effective implementation i can
assure you that the commission will do
everything to be ready as
we've also said during the negotiations
to
take on these important responsibilities
of supervising the very large online
platforms in a very large online
uh search uh engines
and as well of course in the dma the the
gatekeepers this is very challenging but
the commission will do its utmost to to
to be ready on time
on the international
aspects and i think several members
mentioned it of course dsa and dma we
expect them to be global reference
points there are other important
measures like on ai and the data act and
cyber security uh that of course are
going through the legislative process so
there is a lot of attention
from uh third countries in what the eu
is doing in the ttc we have intensive
discussions with the us on tech
platforms i co-chair
this working group together with the
white house peter harrow and tim wu and
i think we have a high degree of
convergence even though of course the
political situation is what it is in the
u.s i think the problem analysis is
largely shared and there's a lot of
interest and i would say even sympathy
for the way europe is
is is going forward in this in this area
one
issue we are also convinced about is
that we need to work together to project
a democratic human rights fundamental
rights open
internet-based model
across the world we we are seeing of
course very negative developments out
there
less than a month ago with kind of the
support i mean very close cooperation
with the us we launched a decoration for
the future internet which in the
meantime has been signed by more than 60
countries around the world and there
will be others joining very soon this is
effectively projecting the dsa and the
dma vision globally and i think that is
important it's an important reference
for the rest of the world we are being
approached almost on a daily basis
by third countries who want to know more
about the dsa and the dma the questions
that we are
debating in europe are being debated all
across the world how to make the
internet safe and how to ensure that our
fundamental rights can be protected
we have digital partnerships one has
been launched last week with japan there
is one in the pipeline with south korea
with singapore these issues will be at
the core of those digital partnerships
we have a ttc agreed with india also
india has expressed its strong interest
in discussing the dsa and the dma also
several latin american countries so
there is a significant interest around
the world and we we do expect that the
dsa and the dma will be copied or part
of it will be copied around the world as
has already happened in the past i mean
madam sheldon moses was the rapporteur
for the platform to business regulation
for example this has been copied in
japan has been copied in korea and in
other
countries around the world
maybe one specific because there was an
interest in in kind of i mean obviously
digital diplomacy is is really important
in this in this area and in in that
context of course we are
reinforcing also the the work of our
delegations
around the world i'm here together with
a colleague from the eas the european
external action service and one of the
the decision that has been taken is that
the eu will set up an office in san
francisco
exactly to
enhance our capacity for outreach
particularly towards the technology
platforms but also on say technology
trends
this office will work of course under
the authority of the washington
delegation of the eu and in very close
touch with headquarters
timing will be uh after the summer
more details will follow but i think
it's another indication that
the european union will want to kind of
have his voice voice heard
in places around the world where these
issues are are really uh important so i
i leave it there thank you very much
madam chair honourable members
yeah thank you so much i think it's
important to have also
this
insight from the commission first of all
about the opening of the office in san
francisco so so far we only had informal
reports on that it's good that you
confirm it here officially
um but of course also to have your
experience on on other legislation how
they spilled over already
in other countries i guess that's very
interesting i mean we also know about
the famous brussels effect where anyhow
our legislation has impact already on
for example the the platforms i guess in
the us
but now i give you the floor finally you
were waiting so patiently but i think it
is important that we let all the groups
speak and you heard the different
comments but also a lot of very concrete
questions to you so please uh the floor
is yours again
uh such wonderful questions and comments
thank you um so there's a couple here
that i think nicely tied together but it
might not be obvious which is you know
one of the opening questions was like
what do we say to the tech companies you
know like like how do we how do we begin
this conversation and i i think there is
a large opportunity to remind them that
i think i think you guys wrote a law
that's going to help them be more
long-term successful
right that that a lot of these companies
are making short-term trade-offs um that
have long-term negative impacts for
themselves because they're they're right
now the only thing they're accountable
to is profit and loss it's like how fast
can we grow for the least amount of
money well it turns out when you do that
you often burn your future success at
the
at the cost of present success and one
of the ways that that's that's so is i
don't know if you guys are aware of this
but most
industries invest substantially in in
preparing the next generation to work at
their companies
and tech companies do that today they
spend a lot of money on buildings for cs
faculties but because they have this
culture of secrecy right like facebook
has has done a lot of things where they
know they have to keep it secret they
they knew that they they couldn't
release these documents or or talk
publicly or when academics would ask for
data they never gave them because they
knew if they acted in a transparent way
they would have to spend more on safety
right and after my disclosures what
happened they spent twice as much as
they had been or at least on facebook
twice as much as they've been spending
more on safety they should still spend
more but they exactly what they feared
happened right but one of the things
that they're missing out on in terms of
their long-term success is that when
they act in secret secrecy it means
they have to train everyone internally
right now you can take zero classes in
the kinds of of safety interventions
that that i'm advocating for you know
there are zero classes you can take
where you get to uh work with data that
is in the shape of the data that is
inside of social media companies so we
as very smart monkeys are really good at
linear patterns and we're really good at
normal distributions like if i throw a
ball most of us can estimate like where
approximately is that ball going to be
and like where about is it going to land
right we're good at thinking that way on
social media everything follows a power
law a very tiny number of users does
most the posts that get the distribution
a tie number posts get the distribution
at china were pages a tight number of
groups
and the ways of thinking how to solve
those problems there's all these
beautiful elegant solutions that are
possible
in terms of between products that are
safe by design
but facebook has to train every single
employee that works on anything like
that they have to train them internally
because they've never let any data go
externally and i think something's going
to end up happening when the dsa comes
into effect when we start having
external researchers external civil
society groups when we start building
the public muscle of accountability
is these companies are going to start
getting employees that actually know
about how these systems work before they
show up at the door
imagine if our petroleum industry had
students that had never taken a
chemistry class
imagine if our automotive industry had
only could hire employees that had never
machined something before this sounds
crazy we would never do that
and so i think there's a new golden age
where actually bringing more people to
the table will make these companies more
successful they'll get new kinds of
solutions they'll get better talent
they'll be less overhead for them and
and right now inside of facebook the
thing i heard over and over again was we
can't hire anyone there's no one
qualified
guess what that error can be over too
struggling alone doesn't have to be the
solution for facebook we can all work on
building a better future the next
question is like how do we do that
how do we support the researchers how do
we support the regulators of what they
need to learn
one of the big areas i'm working on
founding a nonprofit right now one of
the big areas we're working on is we
want to have an open source simulated
social network right something that's as
messy and as broad as what the real data
looks like so we can have students we
can have we have 14 year olds or learn
about statistics be able to actually
begin getting exposed to data science or
if you're a postdoc and you're a fellow
working with the regulator you have
something where you can go and change
lots of different parameters and say how
does the system perform differently when
we we treat this kind of con you know we
you know change slight different
dynamics in the system
um
we need to be able to train thousands of
regulators in the next you know three or
four years we need to start training
tens of thousands of students every year
because if we want people to be able to
sit and and digest policy proposals or
talk about these laws we need to train
them so working on building out that lab
bench you know the reason we have
environmental science majors is we have
a chemistry lab bench building out that
social network lab bench is going to
transform how we teach how we how we
experiment how we how we move forward
i'm so glad you passed
with
legal protections for whistleblowers i
also encourage doing slightly more
comprehensive support so i was supported
by a non-profit called whistleblowrade
that um also um
i i didn't need financial support but
many whistleblowers do um or they'll
make sure that that person has physical
protection because some whistleblowers
their lives are actually on the line so
i encourage you to look holistically at
those things regarding content
moderation in the united states content
moderation in the united states is not
even on the table because we have
something called section 230 and um it's
a very very polarizing and divisive
issue and so i'm really glad that europe
brought to the table and and validated
this idea that we could talk about
systems thinking and transparency
because those are things that i think we
can advance the discussion on but the
content and freedom of speech debate in
the united states is very very
polarizing and so i i don't think we're
we will not be the leaders in the world
in that unfortunately
regarding um
uh
breaking up facebook
one of the challenges with breaking up
facebook is if we were to look at
instagram in isolation
we see the same problems that we see in
facebook repeated in different parts of
the product
so recommender systems that use
engagement
over and over again have the exact same
problems the reason why they're there is
because they're more sticky they drive
more growth for example almost every
child who uses facebook today they're
recommended excuse me instagram because
let's be honest they don't use facebook
today um
their instagram accounts go look at them
for almost all kids the recommended
accounts that they have are from their
school
and they're either confidential pages so
someone will put up a google form where
you can post anonymous gossip like mean
things about your classmates they don't
get blasted out to the whole school
it gets recommended because it's high
engagement or fight clubs i learned
about this from the principal of my high
school where kids will pick anonymous
fights to to broadcast them out to the
school
and right now and when when they ask
them to take these pages down instagram
doesn't do anything
and so having rights for children with
tech companies really matters because it
will change the whole future for those
kids
um but those problems the market on its
own will not solve them breaking up
these companies will not solve that
transparency having regulators get to
look at the algorithms to coach them
that can have that can have an impact
um
if people get to choose between
chronological feeds and algorithmic
feeds they will almost always choose
algorithmic feeds because they're
designed to be sticky they're designed
to be pleasurable and so just having
consumer choice i don't think we'll will
solve that issue
and then
the last thing
i think there's how do we not kill
innovation
so
the number one thing that allows us to
have innovation is more people who are
qualified to innovate
i want to close with this idea of we can
either
solve problems alone or we can solve
problems together
if you want to have more cool cars train
more mechanical engineers
right train more automotive engineers if
you want cooler social media that does
different ways of solving problems train
more people who understand social media
we are entering a new era because of the
work you all did
right we have never been able to see
inside behind the curtain and so we have
never been able to teach classes on this
before
and you know three years from now i bet
almost every cs department in the world
is going to have a class
on how these social media systems work
and it's going to be possible because
the work that was done in this room and
it was done across europe
and so i think the way innovation is
going to move forward is having more
people being able to weigh in is going
to lead to better discussions
conferences are going to be so much
better like right now the only
conference around like recommender
systems is very small because there's so
few people globally who can sit at that
table
i'm excited to see that conference grow
and grow because we can now have more
more and more different kinds of people
at the table so thank you so much i'm so
proud of you and i'm so grateful for
your work
yeah thank you so much for your
inspiration and i think of course also
for your important feedback that the
legislation we had been doing we had
been working on so hard uh makes a sense
has an impact i think that the these are
very important words from your side i
find it very inspiring how you always
use real life examples for describing
social media um that leads to the fact
that indeed we probably have a lack of
education on social media but i think
you linked it very well to the
legislation so with more transparency we
um basically put into the regulation we
can have also more more experts trained
and understand what social media is
really about um so thank you so much for
being here for answering all of our
questions and thanks to the colleagues
for participating in this very
interesting and lively debate um if
there is not any other business i have
to announce officially the next meetings
and then i close
the addendum item for today so we meet
again
on the 15th of june and on the 16th of
june until then um have a good plenary
today and tomorrow and see you
back in june
you